et expire
donc tu es une masseuse je suis qu'est-ce
que tu fais je suis un poète
et je suis un rêveur non vraiment
oh tu es vraiment un poète ouais
oh c'est albert hey salut eva
me disait juste qu'il y a  pas un seul gars à cette
fête qu'elle a vraiment attiré
il est un peu flasque et d'âge moyen
tu portes son pyjama j'aime être à l'
aise
je peux voir ton pénis quoi
oh mon dieu
mais il est sexy pour moi
tu veux un bisou
ouais
ici pour  une deuxième chance c'est bien quand
tout le monde est un peu plus âgé et plus sage il y a des
chances que les gens vous disent pas aujourd'hui comment
était le travail aujourd'hui c'était bien j'ai eu cette
femme vraiment sympa qui parle beaucoup de son
ex-mari il était terrible au lit
très maladroit aucun sens de  humour si
irritant espérons juste que ce n'était pas mon
ex-femme
um
albert est un perdant
que mon nouveau client est l'
ex-femme d'albert
j'ai écouté cette femme dire
les pires choses sur le gars que je
commence à  vraiment comme
quand albert et moi avons commencé à sortir ensemble,
il a fait ce super plat spaghetti
et moz  zarella mais il s'est avéré que
c'était la seule chose que vous pouviez cuisiner
c'est comme un conseiller en voyage humain j'espère que ce
n'est pas un hôtel
si vous pouviez éviter de rester dans un mauvais
ne devrais-je pas rester oh merde
pourquoi tu trembles que tu  je sais combien
de calories il y a dans le guacamole vous vous en
prenez à lui non je ne sais pas pourquoi j'ai l'impression de
passer la soirée avec mon
ex-femme j'ai merdé cette fois bonjour
albert c'est eva qu'est-ce que vous faites
ici les gars  vous
connaissez quand les gens vous demandent pourquoi nous avons
divorcé, que leur dites-vous pourquoi
je veux dire, leur dites-vous que c'est parce que j'étais
un tel monstre qui payait le cul, d'
accord